in this day and age there's a lot of
kind of
starting from the ground up and making
something out of nothing with our
creativity in our minds and
finding new ways to kind of continue to
push
boundaries and continue to evolve so i
would consider
myself in a lot of my peers
entrepreneurs
i'm sabrina carpenter i'm a singer and
i'm an actress
and i'm a producer i grew up in
pennsylvania in the middle of nowhere
and there was really nothing around me
that screamed
this industry whatsoever other than my
imagination and the fact that i just
loved
to use my imagination and and to make
people smile and laugh and
i couldn't stop singing like that was
that was the main thing is that like
my parents never once told me to like
stop singing
i think it was just always something i
wanted to do i just got really lucky
that
i've gotten to keep doing it
there's been so many times where i
thought it was
the lowest of lows the worst possible
you know thing it could be or way it
could get
and then just around the corner was like
the best thing that i didn't see coming
i just think about my life in little
like moments and
segments and like i almost think about
my life in a montage and the things that
i remember
are like the brightest moments in the
moments where i felt full and like my
heart was full and i felt clear-minded
and
making other people laugh or other
people are making me laugh and just like
that energy that keeps us inspired and
it keeps us wanting to change the world
those moments where we think we have
stupid ideas and they end up being the
biggest and best ideas we've ever had
i hope to contribute more of those to my
life and maybe inspire other people to
do the same in theirs
you